oof ouch in the climactic fight scene in
the hunt you see a lot of falling on the
floor which should hurt but what you
don't see is that under a layer of vinyl
made to look like real flooring the
floor is actually all foam according to
the director to make this elaborate
fight scene work the filmmakers built an
entire set with each stunt in mind a set
that was meant to be destroyed this left
the film's production designer with the
tough job of building sets that were
tailor-made to fit the needs of a scene
without the audience ever noticing
warning spoilers ahead in the hunt a
group of conservative Americans is
kidnapped by a group of wealthy liberal
Americans and attacked for sport no
surprise the satirical film was met with
much controversy the film culminates as
crystal played by Betty Gilpin faces off
against Athena played by Hilary Swank
who helped organize the hunt near her
sprawling Manor where the fight takes
place when director Craig Zobel was
given the script for the hunt all it
indicated was that the climax would be
an epic head-to-head so he worked with
his stunt coordinators special effects
team and production designer to
choreograph a fight scene that was a
standout moment of the movie to map out
the fight the stunt coordinators
constructed their own version of the
home out of cardboard boxes which stood
in for the 60 foot by 50 foot set while
working with the cardboard model the
stunt team came up with the idea of
turning the kitchen island into a stunt
piece by having the characters vault
across it while production designer
Matthew mine had already planned to have
a kitchen island he now had to retrofit
and redesign it to ensure it was strong
and sturdy enough to support this one
stunt to pull off the move successfully
the island was built out of strong wood
and painted to look like concrete then
the top was removed and replaced with a
phone
pad similar to how they use foam
underneath the vinyl floor covering kind
of like a kids Playhouse foam floor for
certain parts of it the two characters
also fight on top of the kitchen table
like with the island they needed
something sturdy but they also wanted
something aesthetically pleasing so the
production designer and decorator picked
out a rustic looking table that fit in
with the rest of the set but because
they knew it would have to handle a wide
they made sure the solid wood table also
had a steel base even average household
items were chosen is strategically
placed so they can be picked up and used
as weapons like this light fixture which
both looks cool and turned out to be
practical and this food processor blade
which was obols idea because it's
something he has been afraid of his
whole life
almost all the props you see from
cabinets to jars are breakaway props
which means they're built to be safely
broken what I learned is once you're
working with this winning breakaway
times you do a lot the next stunt was
perhaps the most difficult one to shoot
moving the fighters from the kitchen to
the living room to make this transition
more dynamic the filmmakers decided they
wanted to use this unusual double-sided
fireplace which the production design
team would need to build Zobel saw a
double-sided fireplace while location
scouting at a real house and thought it
would be perfect for a stunt the
fireplace was built with your standard
drywall and concrete but they laid
special propane lines underground that
the special effects team could use to
increase the height of the flames as the
stunt-double went through the fireplace
the opening of the fireplace was
originally smaller but after some
experimentation they expanded it so that
it was five feet wide by three feet tall
it's a dangerous move so as an extra
precaution they soaked the stunt doubles
clothes with a fire retardant then under
that she wore protective carbon axe and
fire gel to prevent her skin from
burning
following this Athena fires it crystal
with her gun and hits the chimney for
that shot Munn said the chimney was
altered to fit the move they took a
piece out of it replaced it with hard
foam and
rigged it with squibs for the perfect
shotgun effect athena then chases
crystal up the stairs where they do get
out some more but crystal would
eventually need to get back downstairs
somehow that's where these big ropes
came in handy in the manner they're
meant to be large art pieces but the
team knew they could double as a stunt
piece for the first part of the stunt
Gilpin's stunt double was connected to
two lines in a y-shaped that were
attached to her harness the lines went
through pulleys above the set which were
then redirected to a pole station across
the room a stunt rigger made sure the
stunt woman got just the right amount of
tension on her lines too much tension
and the stunt would look fake not enough
tension and she would peel off the rope
right away for the second part of this
stunt she dangled about eight feet off
the ground at the count of she would be
pulled forward then once the rigger
heard this sound he had to make sure to
drop her at just the right speed so she
fell directly onto this table knowing
that she would land on it this had to be
built as a breakaway table and the legs
on the table had to be constructed in
such a way that they would break
immediately on impact for this stunt
meanwhile because the rope had to
collapse it was held up with specially
made breakaway brackets which you can
see here
according to Zobel they had enough
materials to do this fall four times in
the end he says they got it done and
just one or two takes while the interior
was shot on a soundstage it still had to
match the actual exterior of the house
shown on screen a real house in
Louisiana so one element the production
design team had to match with a real
house a hallway with big glass windows
it served as the key part of the set to
move the fight from inside the house to
this small courtyard the window turns
into an active part of the action at the
moment when crystal tries to throw
Athena through it on the first try the
window doesn't break and then it does on
the second try in reality the windows
were made out of a tempered glass which
they chose specifically for this move
this type of glass is strong enough to
not break immediately but when it does
it breaks into tiny pieces as opposed to
sharp shards the stunt actresses were
attached to a rope which was attached to
something stationary now
as a Deadman allowing them to bang up
against the glass without being pulled
through it then for the second attempt
Mun said the special effects team rigged
the glass with explosives that were
timed to go off at the exact moment the
two characters needed to go through the
glass the glass was also retrofitted to
allow for this pulley system put
together by the stunt team which would
then launch the characters out into the
courtyard staging the scene this way
gave them an excuse to move the fight
outside and then come back around the
kitchen for the fights conclusion their
transition from one side of the house to
the other via the courtyard was captured
in one move by this camera on a track
Zobel the cast and crew managed to film
the entire sequence over five long
12-hour days at the very end of the
shoot building the set to support the
fight allowed them to shoot everything
safely and efficiently while still
looking spontaneous instead of overly
choreographed while big parts of the set
like windows in the fireplace were most
crucial even the most unexpected objects
and set decoration helped advance the
fight like this expensive bottle of
champagne Zobel knew he wanted it
therefore crystal to grab at the end of
the fight as a reward but what he didn't
know was how perfect the moment we're at
vina catches it would turn out to be
when we go to shoot that portion of the
scene on the very first take hilary kind
of dove in and did this amazing football
cast that I certainly did not anticipate
and I don't think anybody on set
anticipated her really going for it that
much a cheer erupted on set as she
caught the champagne
[Laughter]